My wife is going blind and she doesn't want my help.
I wanna wake up every morning and tell her that I love her,...
...that it's all gonna be okay...
...but she doesn't wanna hear any of it.
I wish I could do all the cooking but she insists on doing it on her own.
She's even figured out the laundry.
She still insists on going to work and taking the bus alone.
My heart stops every time I think about her crossing the streets of downtown.
So, even though she doesn't want me to,...
...I follow her every day without her knowing.
Because that's what true love is, right?
There's more than just a feeling,...
...it's an action.
Cecilia will never know how much I do for her, and I don't ever need her to know.
That's how I still love her even though she doesn't want me to.